once you establish yourself as a working
television director do you interview for
your next job oh yeah yeah you do a lot
of it you know once so it's a lot of
General meetings before you ever get
hired which is basically
the ru well I get along with you are you
crazy meeting you know what I mean like
um and you do a lot of generals so a lot
of so more and more people can say oh
really
yeah
a competent person it's a nice enough
person like
you get what we're doing over here at
our company maybe you know and somewhere
along the line someone's going to say
okay we're going to hire you like Kenya
Barris did for me in 2017.
um and so then you begin to build your
resume hopefully you get invited back to
a show because that's kind of
so if the general meeting went well and
people were like okay talented not crazy
you get what we're doing over here
getting invited back is the affirmation
of that oh they must not have been crazy
they must have really done a nice job
and they must have really understood
what the show wanted
um the
kind of industry not wisdom but saying
or whatever thought is that when you see
someone with a bunch of one episode at a
bunch of different places it's like well
why aren't you ever going back right
and so
you get invited back then you do more
and more shows
um the beauty of of today that might
mask uh the invited back is that a lot
of shows are doing block episodes where
like you like I did two at one time so
it might look like you got invited back
um but once um you do enough work
the work itself begins to be what vets
you so someone may say oh we're thinking
about or even for like the shows that
I'm unaware where we are looking for
directors you'll say oh they've done XYZ
and you can just look and tell that
they've
have the skill set to do your show
um then you'll probably call
around and see if there are people that
you think people that you know know that
person that can you know give you a
little bit more insight into them so
that's where the reputation and and and
that Community is really important and
then after that you always have some
kind of Zoom which is maybe less of a
meeting
um
like it might they'll get to know you
and you'll probably speak really
specifically to the show so it's not a
general it's like about this show
um and at that point you know I feel
like you're probably
it's probably your job to lose
so I guess the long answer
um to your question is at this point
I'll either get an offer
um or I'll get
um like an outright offer they want you
to do these this black episodes because
they've done enough vetting that they
feel like they don't need to
um speak directly to me or they already
know me or
they want to have a meeting on zoom and
uh
if it's at that point they're probably
highly considering me for the job and
that's the final step
what are a few do's and don'ts for a
general
maybe don't don't speak too much we
might say the wrong thing or I you know
I think the I think meetings are you got
to find a way
to still be yourself
in an unnatural environment you know
because it's it's kind of like speed
dating you know what I mean and so I
feel like
the dues are
to be very clear on
have a very clear
and concise way to deliver your your
backstory and who you are your bio your
origin story
um to be very clear on why you want to
do the show you know hopefully who you
are and what you've done connects to the
show so then it becomes
to make almost perfect sense why you
should be directing it you know
um
don't come in there and be unaware of
the person you're talking to
um there are so many opportunities to
find a connective thread that Google
will help you with whether it's oh you
went to NYU or oh you're from New Jersey
or
um
you worked with the person I know you
know on so-and-so project and they say
hi you know like any little thing that
you know that's not going to get you the
job but it it begins to warm things up a
little bit and I think be be clear about
um
you know what you offer to the show and
ask questions I think to come in and not
have any questions
um
Belize a person who's not very curious
because with with those questions you
gain information
you know
um not that I'm the I'm the model for it
but like I'm thinking like like you
asked me a question about this person
versus that person and I'm like well
what is that person's goal because that
that's going to help me kind of
you know answer the question and
sometimes in a meeting asking questions
helps you figure out
what you might not want to say
and just absolute don'ts
um well yeah it's the don't come in
there unprepared you know whether that's
in understanding the person in front of
you and understanding
um it their bio or some portion of it
that you can because sometimes I've come
across a few people where it's like you
scrub yourself from the internet somehow
and I don't know how you do that but I
don't know anything about you
um so their personal bio their
um their bio here at this job what do
they have the power to do
right
um are they the person who hires are
they the person who weeds out and then
you know this is the meeting that gets
you to the next person who may actually
be able to hire like you know uh what
projects are they proud of is has
anything been greenlit recently or you
know did a show just Premiere last week
and watch that show and be able to talk
about it you know because that shows
that
you're invested in what they do as well
um because at the end of the day I think
the way I try and view working
professionally in a world full of
collaborative creative people is I want
as many people to make their projects as
possible
I'm here to be a support for that
whether it's maybe it's feedback or
maybe it's directing an episode or you
know maybe it's a go get them champ you
know but uh
providing that type of energy I think is
something that folks are
happy to have around them
and lastly how early is too early
for what for to show up at one of these
meetings oh how early it's too early to
arrive I mean
you know
make sure you're there on time uh I I
get I try and get there 30 minutes early
but then you won't see me in the lobby
until you know five minutes before you
know what I mean okay maybe maybe 10.
10 is a good amount of time because I
wanna you do want to give yourself time
to get in
you know sit down you know reap you know
run through whatever you might have
prepared again sometime it might be
going into the bathroom and stretching
out a little bit or whatever whatever
you need to do
um but don't don't walk in there at 128
for 1 30
um Because unless you've got some
abilities that I don't have to smoothly
transition to meeting mode
you don't go in expecting to be hired
instead you go in to make it impossible
for them not to hire you
how is that different so you know
the way I view it is and this is like
I think I think a big takeaway from the
book is that I'm I'm big on
viewing things through the prism that I
can control right and and viewing things
in a way that
you know
really prevents
getting beaten down by the realities of
of what we do in a world where you're
selected and or not selected for reasons
known and unknown
um fickle and and arbitrary and
sometimes spot on and so
um
my thought was when I was trying to get
jobs and and I I still carry it with me
is that I understand that there are
people who will be easier to hire for a
particular job and that happens now
um you know
but
my job is to come into this meeting and
make it
the most challenging decision for them
to not hire me
so what does that mean
I'm going to come in and tell my bio
origin story and it's going to be you
know concise it's going to be
um you know whatever funny it's gonna
I'm gonna give you the best me that's
honest but designed to you know connect
with what we're
talking about here is a project as
possible
I'm going to show you that I've done my
research
I'm going to speak about the show
because I've watched enough to develop a
point of view that's informed I'm going
to be interested in asking questions
about it I'm going to let you know
outright how much I want to do this show
um you know all the things that make it
where you're like looking at the grid of
people up for it you know you may have
somebody that's done more
work than I have in this particular
genre or just at all but maybe they
weren't as
exciting a meeting
maybe they didn't outright tell you they
want the job maybe they didn't you know
get into a really deep dive conversation
into the show
you know and I understand why you would
still hire them over me if you know for
all the reasons that make hiring what
hiring is but I want that to be a tough
decision
and my thought was if I if I can
build
a Rolodex a database a spreadsheet full
of meetings where that was the end
result at some point somebody's gonna be
like all right this is the right one
for him
I see so yeah so then it's kind of
nebulous that's like I'm going there to
get hired versus I'm going to make sure
that they can't not hire me because that
seems like it checks more boxes I feel
like they're that's clear to me and it's
the actor's audition right like the
actors audition is you can't you can't
audition to get the job
like
that if you do that you're going to
be depressed because how many jobs are
you going to get you have no control
over that you know but
what you can do and this is from me on
the other side of the table like
watching auditions like what you the
auditions that land are I can tell that
you had a perspective
you made a choice you prepared and you
executed on that choice and whatever
those three things were you gave you
provided a tape that was your best
presentation of those things and then
ain't nothing else you can do about it
you know what I mean like we can debate
oh like we might say oh well she's you
know the person that we've already cast
for her sister she doesn't look anything
like her and it's a big stretch because
that's important and so like no we don't
hire that person and they may have been
the best person but you know there's
another reason why they might not have
gotten a job
and so
you know directors are auditioning in in
a similar in in somewhat of a similar
way
um and just taking the reins and making
sure like you show them what you can do
show them who you are and let them
decide but make it hard
and how do you say I would love to take
on this opportunity or is that what you
say that's what I would say
outright
so so maybe two other people might think
that but that's too passive and they
just go okay great so yeah just please
keep me in mind like you basically let
it be known let it be known I want this
because there's and and you know my
estimation is that
on on this fictitious sheet of paper of
names that are that are up for something
you know maybe one or two of them are
doing it because their agent said they
should
all right and maybe
it's attractive to the people behind the
show because oh it's so-and-so
you know or maybe they you know used to
be so-and-so like
cool
but like I'm gonna come in and I'm gonna
there will be no doubt you know
um and in a world of meetings where
folks are having 40 meetings a week like
these things begin to
stand out
and lastly do you send a follow-up email
or even a card
um I well it depends you know sometimes
I have there are a lot of relationships
where
I don't have any of these folks
information because the Reps at the
meeting and then you go and that's kind
of how the Reps remain where they remain
you know as the conduit and then
sometimes I'll have uh folks who will
uh yeah folks who will like be like oh
here's my card and then that kind of
lets you know
hey the meeting went well but also they
have a maybe different kind of
relationship they're trying to build